um so the first replay review we're
going to do today
is for fitzy somewhere high champ three
i have rank turned off that's a good
idea fitz i'm very proud of you for
doing that i want to hit gc by the end
of season if possible i feel like i have
issues with positioning and being
consistent i also want to be able to
carry my teammates that could be a topic
of conversation that we go into but
let's see
how we can help out our boy fitzy today
right here chad what do you think fitz
should be doing because sometimes the
the only thing that some players believe
is that you have to defend from in here
right which is not true you can defend
from anywhere on the field
what i would like to see fitzy do here
is stop stop his car right here and then
jump up for uh when it bounces clear it
to the side you do not have to go in the
net and turn around to uh defend your
net you just don't have to you can jump
at anything he had full boost as well so
once it bounces off there it's much
easier
than to go in the net and turn around
like you did here that's just a
decision-making error this is just a
really good mechanical shot you could
have hit it more top left corner but you
hit it in the net i'm not gonna gripe on
it at all champ three you should
definitely know that this touch right
here you're not gonna catch it you
already hit the ball way too hard
to avoid this completely what fitzy
should do here is grab this boost and
slow down whoa you smacked that ball
up to the gods above and you probably
knew this guy was gonna come and lace
you so it's like right here you're not
gonna get this
even if you jump off the wall it's kind
of from an awkward angle it's going to
be a bad 50 either way
the biggest issue i have with this
entire thing right here is this jump you
weren't even close
but the jump here off the wall chat is
just the worst thing you can do in this
situation
because
he's going up for it and now he is
flinging himself completely out of the
play he's never going to be able to
recover off this very fast whereas if he
just you know let's say he does get that
hard touch off the wall you can just
stop your car not jumping then you're
and then you're back defending so that's
the biggest issue is you just flung
yourself out of the play doesn't lead to
a goal but it certainly didn't help like
just just looking at this
what do you guys see he could have hit
the ball but should he hit the ball from
his angle
from where the opponents are and where
his teammate is
should he touch this ball at all he
should not go for this
at all look at where his teammate is
chat one bad shot one bad 50-50 which is
all i see here or
moving too far up and not doing anything
all leads to a goal so it is way too
risky
way too risky to go for this completely
it gets him scored on what he should be
doing is he should be stopping his car
right here as soon as he sees his
teammate flipping into an opponent's
corner you have to protect your side of
the field you have to
there's there's no other option here
there's no angle to shoot based on where
fitzy is honestly he should be over here
but being midfield is never a bad thing
but moving up into this play that he has
no chance of getting no chance of
scoring with his teammate in a bad
position that is just
not a good decision all around so he
moved way too far up into a play
and it's just a bad situation all around
when you see a teammate in an opponent's
corner don't also be
in that bad situation that's
biggest takeaway from that situation i
will not i don't want to blame you
fitzy for this pass at all
this is a good pass that the opponent is
more ready for than your own teammate
which sucks like your teammate should be
getting a 50 50 on this no vision blind
pass he sees his teammate the entire
time he sees them bottom right corner
right here under the boost
or at least he should he sees him it's a
it's a good pass should his teammate go
for this i know we're looking at it in
hindsight now but no
for the exact same reason that i gave on
the last play it's way too risky when
you're this far away from it if demon
was closer he should absolutely go if
fitzy hit it closer to demon on the pass
he should absolutely go but given the
situation what happens the momentum of
the ball is going toward the opponent
and away from his teammate which always
most of the time ninety percent of time
leads to a bad 50 50. so he just should
fake challenge and go back because if he
fake challenges here the opponent's just
giving him the ball and especially with
fitzy passing off the wall he's not
gonna be able to recover fast enough to
be back if his teammate misses which is
what leads to the goal so so far these
three goals that they've given up is all
risk reward and they're it's all risk
with not enough reward if the reward is
a guaranteed goal go for it but the
these
situations are basically just
uh thank you so much they're not even
scorable someone at tick-tock chat gotta
take risks uh he can easily clang that i
don't think he can the ball's too far
away from him and he was too f he was
too far away and the pass was going away
from him it is
it's risky i understand taking risks
uh but when they're stupid you're gonna
get scored on like they do there so it's
not worth the risk
you should absolutely take risks when
they are uh given
like when the opportunity is given other
than that it's just stupid so pretty
much the exact same situation except the
roles are reversed here demons hits the
ball way too you know not not a great
pass but it is a pass fitzy isn't ready
for it it's coming it's closer to the
opponent than his own teammate so my
question here chat is should fitzy go
for this or should he have rotated back
in the net to have a better chance or
already been closer we already know the
answer he shouldn't go for this he's way
too far away the ball is closer to his
opponent you got a shadow defend rotate
back in the net that's your best chance
of saving this and it's probably not
looking well in that regard either it's
a bad it's just a pass that's better for
the opponent and not for your team risk
reward there's way too much risk it
leads to goals man so when you take
those
four risks now they've all gone poorly
so it's not it's not even a risk it's
just a stupid stupid decision
boom
what a flick
and then a great pass the opponent
that's what i
like champ three this is champ three
game play by the way to anyone who's
just tuning in
um this is just
inconsistent gameplay
very inconsistent gameplay it's like i'd
see a lot of players jump here right a
lot of players would jump and try and
aerial this and try and beat jaden or
take the ball away or whatever i think
that's an option you could you could do
it but looking at it here does he need
to
look at where jaden's shooting the ball
the goal is not in the corner bro
who cares
let your opponents make bad mechanical
mistakes because this guy's air
dribbling the ball into a corner in the
net yeah you got to go for it but this
guy's just dribbling it over here just
let him make the mistake i love this
from fitzy by the way just like letting
this guy flop onto the ball look at this
man a bunk
this is so unnecessary man
so i like that decision making from
fitzy that's that's very nice good job
the way fitzy plays is just so risky he
doesn't need to do half the things he's
doing a lot of risk without a lot of
reward um ways to work on that or just
being more patient i think the
inconsistencies come not from mechanical
mistakes but from decision making
mistakes
which comes from trying to think of what
you're doing a little bit more than just
doing the action because fitzy's clearly
very good mechanically he knows what
he's doing his movements and flow around
the field are just kind of silly so and
it leads to goals where they definitely
should have won this game they played
way better than the other team
but they just gave too many goals to the
other team so they wound up losing when
their plays in scoring were just so much
better that's that's my biggest takeaway
from that match for fitzy is just work
on those decisions man try and be a
little bit more patient and you're going
to rank up so fast just try to avoid
those avoidable goals at all costs so
hopefully that was helpful it's kind of
a weird replay because there's nothing
mechanical no no mistakes really
mechanically were made it's just all
decisions hopefully you learned
something there chat